[Applause]
come on
[Applause]
[Applause]
everyone go
Jackson
you got a little
yeah I figured you're one souvenir
compare the edges YouTube
foreign
[Music]
The Man Behind Hollywood's worst video
game movie adaptations and those
live-action game trailers to give people
unrealistic expectations so I hate those
you two know the drill sweep every room
make sure no one's home
this could be our new safe house another
day at the office [ __ ] nice office
[Music]
I'm kidding it
well that was easy
imagine how much below this surface is
seen
it's always snowing in L.A
kitchen's clear
what are you doing seeing if anyone's
been shopping
I don't know if this is expired milk or
some free range green tea kombucha
[ __ ]
there's cigarettes and coffee to start
the day
hey guys check this out
classy [ __ ] huh
seems like a real down to earth dude I
hope you didn't make it why because he
turned on your dumb half man half horse
rom-com screenplay the centaurs man I
told you centaurs
can't even much of a producer if you
couldn't see Hollywood's next billion
dollar franchise
clearly
move on Ponyboy
room's clear anyway
if it doesn't fall out of a clear 3x
structure
di2 I wonder Jackson come on just one
sec
piece of [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] dude
[Music]
Welcome to the zomboculus
I hate to tell you but you picked the
wrong time to come to town
bet you thought your world was in chaos
didn't ya
try this emphasized bitten infected
somewhere between alive and dead
[ __ ] doesn't get more real than this
Los Angeles
City of Angels or as we like to call it
hella
just think of it as your own stylish
sunbaked zombie smashing playground and
trust me these hungry bastards are
everywhere
but don't worry
there's more to this city than Hours of
Happy skull busting it's crawling with
Adventure and crazy ways to pass your
final days
we've got all the usual tourist
attractions
albeit with a uniquely horrifying vibe
there's loads of survivors you want a
blast on a trend special
although are you getting the pizza
they're all as mad as the flesh eaters
[Music]
seems they like you a lot Jacob
I'll take it from here
we've all dreamed about smashing zombie
brains right
whether you're slicing kicking stomping
burning or whatever it is you're gonna
really feel it I guess dreams do come
true
and [ __ ] man you'd be amazed at what
these angelinos keep in their Hollywood
houses
machetes swords hammers bigger hammers
are those bear claws and naturally a
holy [ __ ] ton of guns
if that doesn't do the job DIY is always
your friend
this is too awesome
oh and that zombie butt
came with a little Papa Z power
switch is always handy
freaking zombies these reanimated
[ __ ] come in all shapes and sizes
big ones
little ones Smart Ones no not new dubby
noisy ones I hate the noisy ones even
pretty ones you really can't knock their
stuff
except for this guy
Different Strokes for different folks
right as long as you're dead
stay dead
[Music]
so
what do you say
you in hell
foreign
[Music]
was uh into a bit of directing too
I wonder how many young actors got their
big break right here
the old boy sure was adventurous we've
got voyeurism
golden showers
denial
pegging classic
and uh mummification
everything was on the menu with this guy
everything is absent ours
I reckon 50 50 chance this is spiked
and roll the dice boss
[Music]
the usual
nah I'm good
sure Rudolph can't hurt anybody now but
uh this could
come on YouTube
hey Brad
thank you
clear boss
here boss
you're kidding me
Dead Island two we're here coincidence
huh what do you mean finding a video
game set in a zombie apocalypse when
we're in a zombie apocalypse
huh
life imitating art
anyway
let's see what this is about looks like
I'm going for a smoke then
what's Alexa game control
how about I find out for you no chance
[Music]
hey zombie get over here
hang on what happened I don't know
come on come on
uh you might want to find a weapon
guys give me my ax
it's like you've played this before
[ __ ] it time to go local
how are you doing this
[Music]
get him
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
you gotta see this
thanks for the help guys
quit your bitching let's get back to it
now
[Music]
to get anyone's hopes up unless there's
some kind of feral zombie commune hidden
in these walls we might have found the
greatest Safe House in L.A we're not
safe here yet
safer here in Santa Monica hope here was
Secure look what happened there like
ants on a popsicle stick exactly at
least here there were four walls and
enough booze for you two to be
entertaining especially considering
there's no one else here
let's do a second sweep the entire place
got to be sure
white dudes tend to stick around way
longer than you think
there aren't any Rudders here and as far
as rosting goes he's dead probably eaten
by a zombie or choked to death on one of
his dildos I'm no expert but I'm going
with dildo so let's just say this place
is secure and
happy hour
it's secure when I say it's secure
now come on let's finish this
Brad you coming
this keeps getting worse
I don't know if they can come back from
this
something funny
come back to what
City hit rock bottom long before the
outbreak [ __ ] maybe for you turn up
here on the idiot bus screenplay in hand
but for actual locals like me
La had character character
really
the city was the capital of [ __ ]
people over and ripping their hearts out
at least now folks are being honest
about it that out there that's La
finally showing his true character no
longer hiding behind an inflated plastic
smile while sucking out your soul
look Brett I don't mean to offend you
man I know your whole family is dead and
all but
think about it like this you're alive
free free from rejection free from
belittleman free from the [ __ ] Rat
Race that plague this terrible City and
the douchebags the sycophants the
rostines of that sad sad world they're
gone
debt nowhere to be found
him
morons you were saying Jay right yours
huh should we shoot him he's got no
chance out there and I ain't sharing a
bathroom with him in here close the door
hey Mr Rossi not the best time I know
but I took your notes on board page one
rewrite maybe I can hold these guys off
while you're reading you're gonna let
Eduardo in who said Ward up
yeah
[ __ ] he survived I'm losing my touch
[Applause]
[Music]
oh [ __ ] you're gonna be a thousand
riders in here
time to go to work
[Music]
foreign
never seen so many before
so many that anyone who didn't see us
fight them
probably wouldn't believe that we
actually did find them
well we did
totally did
fight them
what now I didn't grab that aisle too
holy [ __ ]
party's over
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]